نعم اا من جانب اخر ندد المطران حسام نعوم
رئيس الاساقفه الاندليكان في القدس
باعتداء مستوطنين على المقبره
البروتستانتيه في منطقتي جبل صهيون
السلطات الاسرائيليه بمحاسبه المعتدين
كاميرات المراقبه اظهرت اثنين من
المستوطنين وهم يقومون بتكسير الشواهد
القبور يوم الاحد الماضي وتعد هذه المقبره
من المعالم التاريخيه التي دفن بها عدد من
رجال الدين المسيحيين وتعرضت الاعتداءات
المستوطنين مرات عده اخرها عام 2014
عن هذا الاعتداءات معنا من القدس مراسله
الجزيره نجوان سمري وخالفه نشاهد المقبره
وما جرى فيها نجوان
في اليوم الاول من هذا العام يوم الاحد
الماضي في وضع النهار بحسب كاميرات
المراقبه التي رصدت اثنين من المستوطنين
الذين يقومون بتكسير شواهد القبور
والصلبان الموضوع على هذه القبور في هذه
المقبره التاريخيه القريبه جدا من باب
الخليل في القدس المحتله تم تكسير 30 قبرا
في هذه المقبره وهو الاعتداء الثاني في
السنوات الاخيره كان هناك اعتداء اخر في
عام 2014 على هذه المقبره تحديدا وتم
تكسير ايضا اربعين قبرا في حينه وبحسب
المسؤولين عن هذه عن هذا المكان المقدس لم
يتم اعتقال او محاسبه اي من المعتدين على
هذه المقبره ويقولون بان هذا يؤدي ويشجع
على مثل هذه الاعمال هذه المقبره واحده من
عده اماكن همم
مقدسه اخرى بالنسبه للمسيحيين من الطوائف
المختلفه في مدينه القدس التي تتعرض بشكل
دائم لمثل هذه الاعتداءات بحسب مصادر
كناسيه في الخمس سنوات الاخيره تم رصد ما
لا يقل عن 100 انتهاك بحق الكنائس
والمقابر ودور العباده وايضا العقارات
التابعه للمسيحيين في فلسطين التاريخيه
ولكن ايضا تحديدا في مدينه القدس قبل
اسبوع فقط تعاملنا مع ارض همم تم
الاستيلاء عليها من قبل جمعيه العاده
الاستيطانيه في بلده سلوان المحاذيه
للمسجد الاقصى وهي تابعه لدير الروم
ارثوذكس وكان هناك احتجاج كبير من قبل
مجلس الكنائس الاعلى في مدينه القدس على
هذه الاستلاءات على الاراضي والعقارات
التابعه للكنائس المسيحيه في مدينه القدس
العام الماضي كان هناك كيان شديد اللهجه
من قبل ايضا المجلس الاعلى للكنائس في
القدس ادام هذه الاعتداءات المتواصله وقال
بانها اعتداء صريح وواضح ومتزايد على
الوجود المسيحي في في الداخل الفلسطيني
وتحديد وفي مدينه القدس تحديدا معي هنا
الاب حسام نعوم وهو المسؤول عن هذا الموقع
همم ابونا يعني تقول بانها ليست المره
الاولى وهذا اعتداء
ناتج عن خطاب كراهيه متزايد ومتواصل
متواجدين هون اليوم نحب نكون همم الوقت
اللي فيهم نحتفل بالاعياد راس السنه
وبدايه سنه جديده فيها تفاؤل معين ان يكون
متواجدين في محل اللي همم تم الاعتداء
عليه بصوره همجيه مقززه ارهابي نعتبرها
وهو اعتداء على المقدسات المسيحيه وهو جزء
للاسف من منظومه نحنا بنشوفها متزايده في
مدينه القدس وفي اماكن متعدده في
البلد المقدسه وفي البلاد المقدسه بشكل
عام فهذا اشي هالقد مزعج شيء احنا بنطالب
محاسبه المعتدين بصوره فوريه وبالذات انه
نحن في قدامنا صور مصوره وفي فيديوهات
اللي بتثبت همم المعتدين على هذا المكان
هناك ايضا تزايد انت ما قلت لكم قليل على
كل الاماكن ودور العباده التابعه
للمسيحيين بكافه
الطوائف فهل هو ايضا اعتداء على
هل هو اعتداء على وجود المسيحي على
الاقليات ما يتعرض له ايضا او تتعرض له
الاماكن المقدسه الاسلاميه تحديدا في
القدس يشبه الى حد كبير ما تتعرض له هذه
المقدسات التابعه للكنيسه المسيحيه
الواضح انه في تزايد احنا عم بنشوف خطاب
الكراهيه ايضا في تزايد همم بنشوف التطرف
اكثر واكثر كل مره يعني كل ثانيه احنا زي
ما حكيت سن الماضي احنا همم مجلس رؤساء
كنائس القدس اصدارنا بيان شديد اللهجه على
شعورنا بعدم الامان
وممتلكاتنا ومقدساتنا في هذا الظرف اللي
هو صعب يعني احنا اليوم العالم كله عمال
بيحكي على حقوق الانسان على حريه عباده
واحنا في ال- ال- المكان الاقدس بالعالم
كمسيحيين كنيسه القيامه عمالين نتعرض في
بيتنا الى مثل هذه الاعتداءات هذا غير
مقبول هذا يجب ان يدان ويجب من كافه همم
ارباب السلطه في اسرائيل وطبعا في كل
العالم حتى يتم محاسبته الاشخاص
نعوم رئيس اساقفه اللي كان في القدس شكرا
جزيلا لك اذا ليلى كما سمعتم يعني هذا هذه
الاعتداءات تتواصل بحق المقدسات المسيحيه
في القدس وفي سائر ارجاء فلسطين التاريخيه
في ال- همم عام الماضي او في نهايه عام
2021 كانت هناك محاوله لحارق كنيسه
الجثمانيه في مدينه القدس والسلطات
الاسرائيليه رغم انها تعرفت على المعتدي
اصدرت بيانا قالت فيه بانه مختل عقليا
كانت هناك ايضا حارق لكنيسه في مدينه
طبريا داخل الخط الاخضر هتقطع قبل همم
بدعه سنوات ايضا لم تتم محاسبه الجنى
ولذلك هذا يتكرر بشكل دائم سواء كان على
المقدسات المسيحيه او الاسلاميه في مدينه
القدس تحديدا
الاعتداء عليها في القدس